donc une partie de la force est séparée
de la structure est ce qu on marche en
compte du sport en dessous de cette
structure
quand on dit qu'une image vaut mille
mots on peut dire que celle ci a eu
beaucoup d'impact on vous parlait on
vous en parlait hier sur un professeur
de l'école louis joseph papineau de
montréal qui déplorait dans une vidéo
l'état lamentable de son gymnase c'est
bien pascal harrison le gymnase a été en
partie fermée pour tiens tiens tiens des
travaux d'urgence travaux d'urgence
patrice en fait déjà hier qu'on était de
passage y avait à tout le moins un
ingénieur de la commission scolaire de
montréal qui était de passage et en fin
de soirée on a décidé que justement une
partie de la structure de béton au
plafond et inquiéter suffisamment pour
qu'on ferme une partie de cet énorme
gymnase là qui est séparé en fait en
quatre plus petits gymnastes donc l'un
d'entre eux sera fermé pendant deux
semaines et le temps qu'on réalise des
travaux pour stabiliser cette partie en
béton là et après aussi on va travailler
un peu sur le revêtement mais les
véritables travaux eux seront accomplies
d'ici les trois prochaines années
à sigean je suis allé revoir
l'enseignant qui avait lancé ce cri
d'alarmé là bas il était bien évidemment
heureux mais un peu déçu
pourquoi on écoute on devrait pas voir
la face donc
je pense que les enfants nos enfants ont
droit non seulement de l'enseignement de
qualité je pense que ça ils l'ont jeunes
ont ici à l'école mais je pense qu'ils
ont droit où c'est des installations de
qualité du moindrement sécuritaire
monsieur walton qui anciens éducation
physique avait été choqué des réponses
que le ministre nous donnait la semaine
dernière or le ministre dans les
corridors de l'assemblée nationale on
lui a évidemment posé la question ça
rebondit jusqu'à québec
bon le lui a demandé s'il allait visiter
d'une part les comme ce qu'il a dit
c'est qu'elle allait demander certaines
qu'il allait poser certaines questions
pour obtenir quelques réponses que oui
la situation était inquiétante mais il a
quand même dit que québec depuis
plusieurs années donne beaucoup d'argent
ici la commission scolaire de choisir
ses combats
on écoute le ministre de l'éducation ce
contexte de négociation actuellement
mais je me souhaite côté ce qui
m'intéresse ce qui m'inquiète c'est des
enjeux de sécurité pour le personnel
pour les enseignants je vous rappelle
soutenait intéressante au niveau des
investissements dans les écoles c'est un
disciple 400 millions $
donc je pense que les commissions
scolaires sont qu'elle va faire des
banques et on est allé voir la csdm
catherine ehrel bourdon nous elle
répondu oui c'est facile en effet de
dire qu'on doit établir nos priorités
mais on a trop peu d'argent
la toiture plus tôt le plafond là à lui
seul huit cent mille dollars de
réparation et ça ça sera fait mais on se
donne jusqu'en 2017 pour la faire bien
merci
parce que merci